hey what's up guys my name is zachary
welcome back to my game engine series
second episode this week getting serious
so last time we talked about circle
rendering i'll have that video linked up
there and i thought that i would kind of
continue on this this trend of like
filling in all of the features that our
2d renderer is missing and today
specifically we're going to be talking
about lines so if we take a look quickly
what we what we kind of left off with
last time we basically added the ability
to render these circles they can be
filled in that can be not filled in they
can have like this cool kind of fade
look as well and they also exist within
our actual run time so if i hit play you
can see that we render these circles now
with lines and what we're going to talk
about today the primary reason that
we're going to be adding these is for
debug rendering so
as an example you know we have these
kind of uh
like entities in our game that use box
colliders but there's no way to actually
see what the box collider looks like and
i talked a lot about like you know
visualizing physics colliders in that
last episode so i'm not going to repeat
myself here check out that video if you
want but basically it's very important
to be able to actually see what the
physics system sees as opposed to what
is being rendered because the two can
often not match and that again might be
intentional uh it might be not
intentional because there's simply a bug
in our actual engine code so it helps us
during the development of our engine but
it also obviously helps us um you know
during the development of the game
itself because we can actually make sure
that everything is kind of lining up as
we would expect so what i want to be
able to do is draw like a rectangle
around
around this kind of rectangle right i
want to be able to draw these lines here
that indicate the bounds of this box
collider now line rendering can be used
for a lot more than just drawing like
rectangles like that um i mean for
example maybe where we have like this is
our player character and we want to do
like a raycast so that we can see like
if if he's touching the floor or
something like that it would be great to
be able to just easily chuck a line up
even through the actual like c-sharp
scripting code in the future to be able
to actually visualize that kind of
raycast so it's something that we we
want more than just for like you know in
kind of engine visualization but also it
might help developers using hazel to
make the game actually be able to
visualize things a lot of engines have
something like this and of course
rendering lines is quite
um quite useful to be able to do now the
thing that this is not and the thing
that like the way that we're going to
implement it today is going to be like
probably the simplest possible way so
it's not necessarily going to look
amazing like i think if you want like
potentially really thick or really nice
soft lines or whatever in your game
engine you're probably going to want to
go down the same route that we went down
for our circles which is basically like
i just want to draw a quad um like you
might want to draw like a thin uh quad
something like this so this is like a
quad two triangles and then you like
have a shader within that that actually
draws your perfectly anti-aliased line
that is as soft and smooth and whatever
as you want i would probably go down
that route if specifically you are
trying to make a game that revolves
around lines and you need to render
lines for your game because obviously
you would want them to look as good and
as perfect as possible whereas for like
debug graphics visualization it doesn't
matter what they look like we just need
to clearly see them and that's why we're
going to be actually rendering lines as
a primitive type so so far the way that
we've been rendering things if we go
into our opengl render api you can see
that we're drawing triangles so what
that means that's our primitive type
what that means is that we are drawing
uh basically every every piece of
geometry that we render at the moment is
going to be a triangle meaning that it
needs to have three vertices one two
three right and then from there
obviously we can you know fill in this
and render a quad because that's kind of
the basis of our batch renderer but the
point being that um let me just make
this a bit bigger i don't know why i'm
using paint by the way
worst decision
but anyway so um
we can kind of uh you know have these
uh indices here 0 1 2 3 0 or whatever
maybe i'll make it look like this
but we can basically draw these
triangles because that's the basis for
our quads that's also the basis for our
circles because circles we render as a
shader inside this kind of quad
but for lines and what we can actually
do is use a different perimeter type
it's actually a bunch of primitive types
in opengl we can use so points lines
line loop line strip we'll talk about
those in a minute as well triangles
triangle strip triangle fan there's even
like gel quad which i think
might be like or quads
might be like deprecated i'm not sure
all this is obviously up to the hardware
or rather the driver specifically to be
able to support uh triangles is the most
common thing because for most geometry
because gpus love to deal with triangles
and that's just how
especially real-time graphics
programming kind of works
now we do also have the option of lines
now again i want to mention that this is
something that is kind of hardware
specific potentially right like i
remember back back when i worked at ea
on on like the mobile engine that they
had um you know i'm pretty sure that we
couldn't render lines natively so we had
to actually like render quads or render
triangles you know and then run a record
and do all of that fancy stuff so it was
a little bit more complicated because
the hardware for some reason open gles
or something i don't know what version i
don't know what driver but it didn't
support line rendering and so you have
to be aware of like your target
platform your target architecture now
hazel whilst it might maybe support
mobile hardware later
uh at the moment we are focusing on just
windows and modern gpus right and
because of that like i have no interest
in trying to attempt to support stuff
that maybe might work in the future uh
we'll cross that bridge when we get
there it's kind of the mentality we have
here because it's hard enough to build a
game engine not to mention something
that supports absolutely everything
right so we're going to just use lines
for now and um the reason why i'm giving
you this background is just so that you
have an idea of like what is possible
and just through my experience right but
um i think it should be fine on pretty
much any modern hardware it should
especially desktop gpus should easily be
able to draw lines and we'll have no
problem with it now there are two more
things right
so what we can do first of all is using
lines if i want to just draw like
something that is you know this is the
line tool right if i want to draw
something that is like you know
outlining this rectangle well that's
very easy to do i can just basically
draw four lines like this
now how would this look like and how how
does that compare to our current kind of
methodology of drawing this uh quad well
first of all one thing you might notice
is that when we draw quads we actually
draw elements so this is an indexed draw
call opengl for some reason calls like
index buffers like element buffers and
indices elements i don't know who and
why i made that decision because it's
very different from any other api where
it's just called index and i think that
makes more sense to be honest but anyway
so draw elements draw index same thing
but the point is what we do is we
actually have an index buffer and if we
look at this index buffer that is inside
renderer 2d 2d
then you can see that uh here it is the
our quad index buffer you can see it
follows this kind of pattern of zero one
two two three zero and then the offset
increases by four so that the next time
we do it is four five six six seven four
but basically the point is that we're
creating this index buffer that lets us
not duplicate vertices two and one
right so these two vertices are reused
when we draw a quad we don't we draw two
triangles like this
right but then these two vertices that's
that's great whatever that's even worse
um these two vertices are obviously the
same
so we don't need to duplicate them
now if you have like i don't know if you
have like a cube or something
uh you know you can also kind of save
some vertices potentially or so you
might think but we have a different
problem here because with cubes usually
um if we need normals which very often
we do need normals you'll note that even
though this
single vertex might be shared by like
three triangles
or even more right if we have this
situation that's one two let's do this
one one two three four five six
triangles are sharing the same position
however they might have different
normals because
this face is obviously facing that way
that face is facing this way this face
is facing this way and so we can't
really get away with not duplicating
that vertex because a vertex is more
than just its position right it can also
have other vertex data
inside like the vertex attributes and so
that's a bit of a different story again
not that relevant here because this is
hazel 2d but just something to be aware
of now for a quad though that is
entirely facing the camera and again we
don't have normals either
obviously these two we can get away with
not having six unique vertices for three
triangles because each triangle is three
points we can get away with only having
four and then use something called an
index buffer i'm pretty sure i explained
all of this in like the index buffers
episode but that was like probably years
ago anyway the point being how does this
tie in with lines if we want to draw
this kind of red line outline thing well
with lines uh our story is a little bit
different because line only has two
points and because a line has two points
like this
um that means that we don't really like
if we were to use an index buffer well
it would just be zero one and then if
it's zero one then we don't really need
an index buffer because we can just use
draw arrays instead of draw elements and
that will just work and so that's what
we're going to do today now i was
talking about all these other primitive
types and it's kind of important as well
because you can see we have lines but
then also line loop and line strip so
what's that all about well line strip
keep opening hazel line strip is
basically
uh you know pretend that we wanted to
draw a bunch of lines in a row so we had
like um
[Music]
we had like this line but then after
that we wanted to draw this line and
then this line and they're all connect
connected well here again you might be
like well do i really need to
duplicate these vertices because if this
is one line 0 1 2 then i need to again
have a vertex here but they join
and that's kind of what a line strip is
supposed to avoid so a line strip just
lets you be like okay well you know what
if you're just going to connect a bunch
of lines together let's not worry about
duplicating vertices just do 0 1 2 and
3. so therefore we can draw something
like this right with just four total
vertices
a line loop is very very similar except
it joins back to the end automatically
so in that case it would join like that
but you know why is it useful we'll
pretend that you are in fact drawing
this rectangle or you're just drawing an
arbitrary polygon like this
well then you would probably want it to
draw back here and so what this means is
that with a line strip you would have to
duplicate that first vertex
so you'd have to be like 0 1 2 3
4 and 5. but with a line loop this last
line automatically happens and so we
don't need that last vertex so it's
useful for this kind of stuff and it can
be efficient we're gonna throw all of
that out the window
why because it's just gonna be simpler
for us to just focus on lines at the
moment and it's definitely going to be
fine for performance again we're not
trying to make something that can render
a billion lines
uh we're probably not going to render
that many lines in general so it's going
to be totally fine for us to just not do
that and so what this will like this
will be slightly less efficient because
it will just be zero one one two two
three and then three
three four i guess
right zero one yeah zero yeah they'll
all be separate lines even though they
are kind of joining and they're sharing
this vertex because the idea is they
might not be and again we are
specifically drawing lines just one line
that's what's going to be drawn right
and then if you want to make a rectangle
out of it well you have to draw four
lines and so you you will get some
duplication but that's kind of the route
that we're going to go down
so how's this going to work well again
we've established that we don't need an
index buffer so what that means is we
can actually copy this change this to
something like i'll just call it draw
lines
uh and then we're going to pass in a
vertex array and this is not going to be
an index count it's just going to be a a
count in fact i'll call this whoops i'll
call this vertex count
so our vertex counter over here is going
to be how many vertices we draw why do
we need this because we'll bind the
vertex array and then call gl draw
arrays instead this is like the more the
more simple way to draw things i'm
pretty sure most opengl tutorials
probably teach this before they teach
draw elements because draw elements
requires an index buffer this just
requires a vertex buffer that's it
so if we do draw draw arrays with that
line's primitive type then it has
slightly uh different kind of
uh parameters here it's got the first
kind of vertex so this is like the
vertex offset of what we're talking
about and then the count is going to be
how many vertices we actually want to
draw which can be vertex count now i
could set up like a you know
just like a primitive type enum class or
something so that we can pass in
anything into here
but thing is i'm going to keep this a
little bit simple because first of all
i'm not a huge fan of this render api i
had kind of a different idea going
forward and i kind of regret the part
that i went down
but also like the more i think about it
the more i'm realizing that we will
probably switch to vulcan sometime soon
just because i don't like opengl is uh
is becoming less relevant to most people
and um
vulcan's going to give us
like more platform support and it's just
going to be a better time in general
because the more i use vulcan the more i
like it compared to opengl but what we
will still do is this is like the
official roadmap map hazelengine.com
roadmap um and
you know we will still kind of get
through this we're not going to pause
and rewrite the engine and vulcan
we're kind of doing the minimum kind of
vertical slice here we're doing our
first kind of minimal viable product you
know one vertical slice i guess of
everything that we're doing here we want
to make sure that we can actually make a
game first and those tools are available
and they're more or less implemented and
then we will maybe loop back and talk
about vulcan and all that stuff so
because of that i don't want to like
spend a lot of time on this opengl kind
of render api and make it perfect
because we are probably going to rewrite
it with something a little bit more
relevant for today's time
right so um that being said though this
is basically all we need to do so let's
go back out and create this and fill it
out in the rest of our render api so
this becomes just a virtual void
draw lines
override let's copy
that go back to render renderer api
and add that in so virtual void draw
lines equals zero
and then i think we also have a render
command
and then in rounded command we just need
to call that so s render api draw
lines
and then
i'll change this to vertex count
this should probably be called index
count by the way this one up here
but yeah that's basically it so i don't
know why this is so this definitely
shouldn't be zero it's zero here because
if it's zero then it will actually
uh use the the vertex arrays index
buffers count otherwise it will
overwrite it but we don't have anything
like that so zero is definitely not
permissible it's not going to draw
anything um okay well great that's
basically all we need so now our batch
renderer needs to be able to create
these lines and the thing is at the end
of the day like remember a line like
lines are very easy to draw lines are
just one point another point that's it
so if we look at what we currently have
like we obviously don't want to put them
into the quad vertex buffer we'll need
to have like another kind of pass for
this just like we had with circle vertex
so we can duplicate let's duplicate
chord vertex
and we'll call this line vertex
and line vertex is going to basically
not have it's going to basically only
have these two text core text index
tiling factor no we can still have an
energy id potentially the thing is
because this isn't going to be a game
side thing though
it's not really going to like implement
uh sorry it's not really going to be
implemented in like the entity component
system like the circle renderer was so
this is something that is entirely going
to just exist in the c plus plus code
for the renderer and then later can
probably be called from like the
scripting language right
as well as like from the editor when we
decide to visualize our physics
colliders as an example so this stuff is
definitely not like i'm not sure if we
should have an ncid but then again i am
picturing that people are probably going
to want to maybe draw lines for inside
their game so maybe we'll keep it for
now but i think that in the future we
might revisit this and make it like a
slightly higher quality line rendering
thing even though i think opengl has
like some kind of gl smooth lines enable
that you can do to like get some
anti-aliasing on the actual lines
themselves so that might be nice but
we'll see okay so line vertex so what do
we do well again i'm going to just reuse
this stuff for now
we'll do a pass and clean everything up
eventually but i'll copy like all this
circle stuff and then again we're just
going to basically find our place with
line so we're going to have a line
vertex array a line vertex buffer and a
line shader
and then if we grab this
we're also going to have
the same thing so a line except we'll
call this just a line vertex count
instead of index count and then it's
going to be a line vertex buffer base
and line vertex buffer pointer which
will be of type line vertex
coming down into circles we're going to
copy this
we're going to rename it to lines and
then yeah again this is just going to be
like a find replace we're going to re
replace
circle with line i'll just match case as
well and there we go okay so let's trim
some of this fat so that's gone and we
just have a position a color and an
entity id
for our buffer layout because that's
obviously the layout of this
um
we're not going to use this
index buffer
and yeah line vertex max vertices again
like do we need like
that many this is going to give us a lot
of lines right because this is times 4
as well this is going to give us like 40
000 lines
because we have 20 000 times 4 which is
80 000 divided by 2 is 40 000 so we
don't need 40 000 lines um again we will
revisit this stuff probably and have
some kind of resizing buffer or flushing
more frequently something like that but
i don't want to kind of spend this
episode talking about that at the moment
so
let's come down here to the shader and
we'll have a line shader
which we'll which we'll make in a minute
uh and then uh let's just set up the
rest of this now i think so what do we
need to do well in start batch we just
need to basically reset everything just
like we do here so i can copy this stuff
and then just make sure that way we are
resetting this so line vertex count
uh line vertex buffer pointer and then
line vertex buffer base as well so we
reset this stuff in start batch in um
flush we will basically see if we have
any lines to flush so we'll check the
line vertex count to make sure it's not
zero and then uh again you know circle
line was already written there
just replace that now we don't need this
draw index this becomes draw lines
instead
right so render command draw lines and
then we have the line
vertex count and that should be good now
why are you upset apparently we have no
render command did i add that
oh i just i didn't actually call it draw
lines awkward so there we go draw lines
um we'll talk about line thickness as
well in a minute but let's just get the
lines rendering in the first place
um
that looks good i think so now let's
talk about the actual
like draw command so we have draw
circles let's order a circle let's make
another one called draw line uh this is
just going to take in two points so
we're going to have a start point and an
ender point so we can have p0
and then p1
we're just going to draw a line from
like one point to another point in 3d
space 2d line right but it's in 3d space
just like the rest of our engine
basically so color um do we need a
thickness now we're not going to have a
line thickness per line because we can't
really do that we're just going to use
something called gel line width to set
the line in a minute
uh fade obviously doesn't exist so we
just have like the points then the color
and the entity id which is probably
going to do nothing at the moment
because it can't really do anything
because we are not drawing them from
entities right so as data line vertex
buffer pointer and then we'll start with
the position so this is easy this is
just going to be p0 now the
transformation so this is already
expected to be in wild space this
position
and the transformation into like
view space and all that stuff will
happen like within within like the
actual uh shader inside our vertex
shader as i guess you would expect so
color
is color
and then we'll set the entity id to
negative one
which is what's happening at the moment
over here
now let's increment this pointer
and i'm going to duplicate this entire
thing except we're going to use p1
uh that's it and then finally obviously
we should set the line vertex count
try again
to plus equals two and that's basically
it now for a rectangle we're just gonna
draw four of these so we'll make the
draw rect function in a minute but this
is basically like it uh
and i think the last thing that remains
is to actually draw our shader
not draw our shader to actually write
our shader so we're binding the shader
here and then we're drawing this which
should bind like the vertex array and
all of that stuff which it does so yeah
we literally just have to write a shader
now so i'm just going to open this
we're going to duplicate we can probably
duplicate within visual studio i don't
know why i keep opening it in like
windows explorer but um because you can
pretty sure you just copy paste here
but if we open up render 2d line this is
our circle shader probably should have
copied the other shader
um
because it's yeah let's go back to like
quad and
we'll just copy
that although we do have all that stuff
we don't need
it'll be more like this one just in the
in the sense that it has these two let's
get rid of this this becomes location
two i really should get that glsl um
or the shader language like syntax
highlighting
but whatever so
we don't have obviously text quartiling
factor that's that goes away ntid will
still keep
um it's separated from the struct
because it has to be flat
is that it i think that's it for the
vertex shader the fragment shader again
i don't like that we we should just fix
this i think across the board i don't
like that these two are
just called color one and or like color
and color one or color and color two
they should be called output color and
output ncid like this let's actually
quickly patch that up for our chord
shader as well
um
because oh it is patched up
what
did i just patch that up oh no i patched
it up in the wrong place
so let's let's also do it in line right
but back in the quad i'll obviously make
this work because we're setting color
and color
apple color and color
2 but instead we'll change that to be
output color and output ntid like this
okay so back in line let me just close
the other shaders so i don't get
distracted um let's get rid of like
basically all of this so output uh so
the v entity id yep is going to be our
output entity id and then output color
is simply going to be the input color
it's very simple we don't need to do
anything here it's just going to be
input.color we'll get rid of the rest of
this get rid of this this becomes
location one no textures and i think
that's that looks pretty good um
that's our line shader again it's super
simple
nothing really to it
let's try and run this so let's try and
render this first of all so back in
scene remember to do this between like
begin scene and end scene otherwise
you'll have to like set up the camera
again which is fine but
uh it won't work if you do it outside of
that
so we'll do draw a line let's just draw
it from like
uh
zero so we'll draw it from the origin of
the world into maybe five meters in each
axis
so we'll set the color to be like
um pink magenta
and the entity idea we'll leave is
negative one okay that's it so if i've
done everything correctly i don't know
if i if i have
but uh we should see like a pink line
even without loading a scene going out
into the world
so it's compiling the shader and there's
our pink line right super simple um
looks like it's about right uh going to
the right position and everything now
how do we make this guy a bit thicker so
the line thickness thing
uh is an opengl global again opengl
loves its globals it loves like just
setting state and then that's kind of it
uh that's just the opengl way it's a bit
annoying but that's how it works so
let's also add something here called um
set line thickness i won't call it line
width i'll call it line thickness i
think that makes more sense
um maybe i should call line width
because that's like
let's call it line with just because
that seems to be what they what they
call it
i was going to go my own way but
whatever
so we'll copy this we'll pop it into
render api as well
set line width i guess we should call it
width
equals zero
and render command needs it as well
float width
set line width
width
and
um if we go back here to here let's
implement it and it's just going to be a
one line opengl function gl line width
and then width
so again this sets it kind of globally
like in most in other apis like in
falcon for example this is something
that you set like into your pipeline
uh
so it would be a bit different in that
sense you can actually also set it have
it set as dynamic state in your pipeline
meaning you can encode it into your
render command buffer or into your
command buffer like before you render a
particular draw call but again it is
something that you do per draw call so
unless you write you know you do the
quad thing that i was talking about and
you write your own shader to render the
lines in that case you can do whatever
thickness you want dynamically per line
and it would still be batched into one
draw call in this case if you want
different thicknesses you're going to
need different draw calls but again
because we're using this for debug
rendering i think it's fine to just be
like you know what arbitrary thickness
of like five and that's across all lines
uh but again if you're making a game i
can imagine that yes you would probably
want different thickness lines uh and
this could be a problem but
again i wouldn't render lines like this
if you want to make a game revolving
around the use of lines
so let's go ahead and
actually like set the line width before
so we don't have this yet but i'll just
um basically set it we'll set it like
this pretty much every frame like that
don't think it'll be that bad for
performance and that way we can easily
just just make the code a bit easier
so let's go ahead and make a float line
width i'll set it to 2 by default that's
not 20.
uh i like a line width of 2.
so start align width and then we'll
obviously have to make some kind of oops
static void we'll make a float get line
width
and also
set line
width this will of course return s data
dot
line width
and this will set it
to it
okay
so now we should have a line width of 2
which we should be able to see i mean we
can try set it to like a higher number
to make sure that works properly but
yeah you can see that it's a bit thicker
and i don't know if there's like a limit
um
i mean like if i guess if we just add 20
i i don't think there is a limit but i
might be wrong yeah it looks like there
might be a limit i think there's a limit
of 10 or something
because i don't think this will just
keep going up
and that didn't really look like 20 to
me yeah so there is a limit um
but you know
again for debug rendering this is
usually fine
what are we at like
28 minutes um okay so we've got some
time this is like a shorter episode than
usual right so let's go ahead and add in
that draw erect
so this is going to kind of be
like
a little bit more akin to how we draw
like everything else so we kind of want
to use a transform we can definitely use
a position and a size i guess i should
probably add that api as well but i
think that this is probably going to be
something that you definitely want to be
able to set a transform for so we'll do
position size and then i'll also make a
draw rect that takes in a transform
because that way we can give it the
entity easily and it will automatically
like use the rotation use the
translation the scale of that i'm not
going to make a draw rotated like
rectangle because again you can just use
the transform
uh kind of overload for that which we
don't have yet but here it is
transform so let's make it work with
both of these
let's create that implementation
with visual assists help
um okay so
s okay so how's this gonna look well
first of all i mean for this case it's
really simple we're just going to call
draw line four times and we already have
pretty much everything i mean we don't
have the the pin like the coordinates
yes so position is obviously going to be
like the center and these are going to
be the half extents
um well they're not going to beat no i
mean size is going to be the absolute
kind of width and height but we're going
to use half extents from the middle so
it's going to be like um how should we
do this uh
maybe i'll just write it out here for
now and
yeah so if it's a vec3 position as well
that kind of complicates things because
we're not sure about its orientation in
3d space
but i'm just going to assume that this
because it's 2d let's do this so p0
will be position
um we're basically probably just going
to use the vec3s
like coordinate let's do this so glm
vect3 we're going to use the z
coordinate as is and then to the x
coordinate we're going to do like for
examples minus size x times 0.5 and then
same for the y
so this is going to be y and y so that's
our bottom left corner and then we're
going to use whatever the z coordinate
is like that
so let's duplicate this one two three
these are like our vertices
um
and uh okay so we'll go kind of in a
clockwise fashion so this is plus plus
and then this becomes plus plus
so that way we're kind of bottom left
then bottom right then top right then
top left is kind of the
order here and then we just need to draw
a line from p0 to p1 with like the color
from p1 to p2 from p2 to p3 and from p3
to p0 simple as that
and that's it i think that should be a
lovely rectangle so let's go ahead and
try and draw a rectangle at the origin
of our world so we'll change this to
draw rect i mean i guess we can do both
just to make sure both work because they
should let's maybe not make this from
the origin though make it from two
and then we'll make draw rect from the
origin with a size of
one
and we'll make it
white and we'll see if we see our
beautiful rectangle
yep so that's off to the side great and
then this obviously
is a nice looking rectangle in the
middle of our world now before i forget
um there's this thing called like
where do we do our initialization i
think it's like up here yeah there is
this thing called like gl smooth line or
whatever
i
don't really use opengl that much these
days geoline's smooth like okay this is
very very bright but um
so enable disable server side gl uh that
will be a gl enable and then line
if enabled draw lines with correct
filtering otherwise draw alias lines c
line width so
and then we have we there's a few
different things that we can use gla
yeah so
uh depending on line anti-aliasing is
enabled to enable or disable chord
you'll enable and disable with argument
lines smooth
line and oh okay yeah so anti-icing is
initially disabled obviously um yeah so
we if we if we enable that it should
provide us with some kind of
anti-aliasing again i suspect this is
very much driver and hardware dependent
but uh maybe this will look better
sometimes in my experience it kind of
causes problems so it kind of looks like
there's now a
almost like a gap here whereas i think
there wasn't one
before um
yeah this looks a lot more solid to me
in terms of actual line but i guess i'll
leave it on
uh and
i think overall especially when drawing
individual lines it looks better
sometimes when drawing connecting lines
is a bit weird but again you know i you
could argue that for rectangles you
could make another vertex buffer or
whatever another like you don't really
need another vertex buffer
but my well i guess you would
well you don't need to you can keep
track of offsets and stuff but my point
is you could maybe do a draw line loop
or like a draw line strip or something
and maybe that would look better or
whatever again i'm not going to bother
too much this is primarily for debug
rendering
so how do we do uh the transform version
well the cool thing is because this is a
rectangle we can actually just reuse our
quad
vertex positions because they're already
perfect and obviously we made them be
like a unit quad meaning it's a one by
one meter quad so because of that we can
easily just
let's grab like a for loop that goes
through it
um
and uh this is it right
and then what we'll do is uh we will
just
basically
do
draw a line
and
it's going to be slightly annoying i
think maybe we should just make like the
vertex positions up here
line
vertices
for
and then this will just be
i
equals
the transform times
s
data
um quad vertex positions i
that goes away
uh and then that way we can just we just
have a little bit more control over this
so we do zero one
one two again you could also kind of put
this into the for loop
oops two three
three and zero i'm gonna i'm just gonna
leave it like this i think this makes
more sense but yeah if you wanted to
you know
again as a as a youtube person i feel
like i always have to explain everything
otherwise people can be salty in the
comments but um you could just basically
set this to be i
i plus one mod
for
right
you don't even need this you just do
glm vect3
vertex equals that
there's my vertex but you need you
actually need the second one so it's a
little bit harder than this because you
need to also have the second one already
done
you can't just draw a line of revertex
like this but i'm sure you could figure
something out like you could make
another for it whatever you can do
whatever you want there's a reason why
i'm leaving it like this and that's just
because it just makes more sense to more
people i think um okay anyway moving on
so draw rectangle with a transform so
now what we can do again to test this
out what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go to like scene and wherever we draw a
sprite we currently call draw sprite
let's replace that with a draw rect
instead
and i'll make this like we'll take the
transform as usual and then we'll just
make it be like a
white i guess rectangle and then we'll
load our physics scene and make sure
that that's all working again it's not
going to work in the runtime because we
didn't override that but you can see
that with the physics 2d and everything
we get
everything's rotated perfectly
everything works and then if we hit play
we get our normal scene but you can see
that we kind of almost get like a
wireframe ish view of everything and it
looks good okay so that is definitely
working
um that's pretty much it i think so we
can render lines we can render
um
rectangles
the next step is going to be to kind of
integrate this stuff with our existing
like physics components so that we can
easily easily visualize them but then
again like you know we already have the
ability to visualize uh circles because
we've already added that so circles now
rectangles are done
um yeah i think it looks pretty good in
general and we're probably ready to
move on with like integrating the rest
of the box 2d stuff because i don't
think we actually have a circle collider
yet so that's going to be the next thing
that we move on to but thank you guys
for watching this video please don't
forget to hit the like button if you did
enjoy it patreon.com best way to help
support this series and get access to
like the the big big hazel's kind of
code i keep calling like big hazel
because this what we're working on is
hazel 2d of course i'll leave your
thoughts in the comment section below
and i will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you